nous sommes ici au manoir de chénier à
marianne un manoir qui a 500 ans d'âge
il date de la renaissance et tout est à
vendre depuis ce fauteuil crapaud
jusqu'à ce tableau en passant par
l'antilope bambara c'est une vente
exceptionnelle qui attire du monde
tous les meubles et bibelots de cette
propriété doivent être vendus ce samedi
car ce manoir a très vite trouvé un
acquéreur
mais une fois cette demeure vendu que
faire des meubles
le propriétaire a eu l'idée de faire
appel aux rouilles ac père et fils
commissaire priseur rompu à ce genre de
vente
c'est toujours beaucoup plus compliqué
pour le commissaire priseur de vendre
sur place d'accès de présentation
d'expositions et ça beaucoup plus de
charme et tous les clients qui viennent
qui viennent de très loin en a certains
qui réservaient leurs chambres d'hôtel
pour être là demain à la vente préfère
voir présenter une tapisseries du xviie
dans un agent de la renaissance les
ouvrir ainsi une demeure privée ou
publique demande une belle organisation
il a fallu tout trier et faire appel à
un expert pour certaines pièces un
pincement au coeur pour le propriétaire
se bat noir appartenait à la famille
depuis les années 50
qu'est ce que vous ressentez qu'en
envoyant si ces gens qui passaient même
qui vont sans doute être vendus et qui
vont partir je vous dirai ça demain soir
c'est un peu trop tôt pour le roi la
maison est encore habité
parce qu'en fait avec tous ces veuves
elle est habitée mais bon demain soir
quand il aura plus rien pour le moment
c'est bien sa vie est en effet chaque
recoin est explorée avec minutie dans
l'espoir peut-être de découvrir un
trésor jeux rien vu de mon goût j'ai pas
fini la visite mais finalement cet
acheteur est tombé sur ce vase
un lot qui avait échappé à la vigilance
des commissaires priseurs
vous avez jusqu'à samedi matin pour
pousser la porte de cette demeure est
peut-être trouvé vous aussi votre
bonheur